hi guys so and were younger and so for
also years I work with young people you
go and which was very great company does
semantic research so a bit more about
that later and I'm not working there
anymore but so was a fairly large piece
of of a liquid called that was a central
party in human text natural language
text and this code was and so the
engineers in the natural language
analysis team and so which include me
shine Doron we kind of developed a
methodology of coping with the fact that
it was this huge piece of code that had
both kind of researching parts and Reiki
and had to go through to run in
production so what I'd like to talk
about exactly that so we kind of reached
a some ideas some of them are pretty
complicated so go on hit ok and it's
like other people are other ideas are
kind of concise and it could stay down
here so and the premise is that to have
long term impact you as data scientists
are supposed to get stuff going for a
long time right I mean you really not
just do this one analysis and stuff
works
I mean do based on analysis and usually
it's kind of left in production and
should be delivering results like till
further notice
so and from the database and see parts
it means that I mean you have to use
sound statistical technique you have to
decode your outputs things like
and I'm not to date scientists so I
can't tell you anything about that but
from the engineering part it means that
your code has to be maintainable because
realistically it will break and the last
time you'll spend debugging it the
better and so what so the whole point is
making code that's on the other hand you
don't invest a whole lot and it's still
researching and it's concise and elegant
and on the other hand you kind of can
make it work to production
okay so I'll discuss it without do three
techniques of doing that it's so let's
get to it
a lot of what I'm going to tell you
about is about interfaces and so let's
begin with an example so what I'm going
to do here is I'm going to show you a
number of examples then I'm going to ask
you like what are the subtle things that
could go wrong because this is actually
correct code it's good in a meaningful
sense so what are the subtle things that
could go wrong I'll spend about 15
seconds to discuss that and then I'll
show you like my ideas about right so
what's wrong here no it doesn't have a
bug right so the thing is like that all
right then it's okay so the thing is
like that you're returning a dict
to your users right so addicting Python
up until the recent version is unstable
which means that when you iterate on it
on different products you get the
results in different orders and it means
that if you were to actually use this
code in a production setting then you
would actually be getting like different
results unless you took special care to
normalize them to reorder stuff right so
that's the sort of thing it could go
wrong
so a worth noticing another is that a
for instance consider the case in which
one of the users gets the result
and then he decides to introduce some
Wayne right so he so it decides that the
short words are worth more than long
words or vice versa
so like without thinking too much it
just like modifies the data structure
returned which means that so if you were
actually to store this data structure to
catch it then you would so other users
of the data structure would get the
corrupted version
so again if there is nothing wrong wrong
with that code but the night guy could
actually be broken because you'd be
expecting it to stay the same and
doesn't stay the same hey and there is
another thing which is like say I get to
dig from you with strings like on the
key part and integers on the very part
and and I don't really know like I mean
I get it from like 15 layers of code
down and I don't really know what those
integers mean I mean die so a so that's
not the problem
so yeah and so what I wanted to show you
is kind of a more future safe way of
doing that and it's less efficient in
terms of like what a performance often
it doesn't really matter that much so
there is a very nice package called
actors in Python how many of you have
heard about it let's look at the BRIT
right
so address is an excellent way of
defining a structure with like a so
essentially a class with a given set of
attributes and with certain semantics of
how do you set them and what attributes
are correct for instance you could only
allow a counts that are integers so no
none else counts and also you know when
you receive such an object that and the
world part is patters object dot word
world
and the count is count so you know that
it's account
something else if you were to like
desire for something else you would call
it something else right and and another
thing you can do is and so another thing
you get from come from matters is it
creates a constructor for you and the
creates validators to the extent that
you ask for validators so you can't make
a count of which is floating point
number and you can convert values so
it's pretty convenient trust me okay so
and what you could actually do to get
the code future-proof what we would
write int we go for this specific case
is we would kind of put the results in
an order T so they would be sorted by
the order of the TCD tokens and you
would then repack that into a couple of
giving one counts which means which is
pretty unambiguous the topo is immutable
in Python so you I mean the value that
you return here it's going to be okay
even if it's catch this it's not to be
incorruptible right and so and that's
kind of any questions about that so
let's talk about that later
it's a good question well you're making
history awkward so I want to know what
word is frequent in your text with this
is this actually pretty frequent things
to do when you write or analyzing some
kind of linguistic phenomenon right so
so I'm going to move so and I'll show
the code example and I would like to
move those to slightly more subtler
ground and so typing is kind of
between yourself and other people and
other people includes you in a couple of
months because you don't really remember
what's in that big thing that you made
so a specifically doing so one option
that AdWords gives you is doing type
checking it could be doing like instance
of so that your accounts are integers it
means that you're introducing a
performance that penalty because
instance of course some may admit
microseconds so one the choice is saying
that it doesn't really matter
another choice is there are some pistol
instructor like spark spark data frames
that guarantee your data type
consistency so you could be using those
right but it's not a strategy to the
same end right and in even more general
approaches so almost any kind of
interface you have with the file it
involves serialization deserialization
so button so how many of you could use
the Python pickles right so everybody
knows about pickle so it's an easy
choice but it's also quite on specific
specific so you could be using a number
of other formats which are not quite as
specific but then you would actually
need to map by tan beta structures to
that format right so for instance to
Jason you would be using marginal or
something like that okay so the good
news is that it's not that difficult if
you're using adders to make something
that converts adders automatically to a
Jason and you would actually be so
actually it's a part of the address
library which is others as big with very
cursory option but in a more general
case it's not that difficult to make it
and makes your code infinitely more more
readable so that we go we develop the
whole sterilization library which used
addresses a type annotation we consider
it out when I was there we consider
sourcing but it didn't happen but it's
kind of not the big difficult to do
something similar so hey so in any case
I do implore you and never have to use
cs3 so like comma separated values if
that option is available if any other or
friend is well because really CSV is the
worst form whatever does anybody
disagree on that but I wanna stand the
record that XML is a in some senses
better than seeing so next thing I
wanted to talk to you about is
minimization right so how many of you
have written code that looks like that
so by that I mean that they have a kind
of a global big and then a single
fighting global single and then your
head like you be in your code by
checking if the data that you want like
the data that you want memorized is in
that date and then you kind of if it's
not then you calculate and then put yeah
so and okay so why is that code but it
was the problem that code yeah right so
yeah okay so mobile state is a very good
answer thread safe is also a good answer
so it's like it stems from essentially
their same function doing two different
things which are like totally destroy no
other is actually not the data science
like thing at all so one of like first
so so the first thing is kind of
calculating the bit count of an integer
which is like for the purpose of data
sizing and the other is storing it in
some kind of affair
which is not a data science thing I mean
it's partially but this the choice of
which cache exactly to use is not a
choice that like you should live inside
your module and why is that because the
lookup table can grow to essentially an
infinite size right so in Python like
integers are like arbitrary length and
even if very limited to like say 32 bits
then you would probably get out of run
before you fill the table which isn't
necessarily a good thing right
it's so the specific thing there is
actually a spread is thread-safe but if
you were to do something kind of more
complicated than it could be get it
become not thread safe and so the good
news is in Python you actually have like
one basic library we're doing cache in
Python 3 which is called LRU cache
inside funk tools which is a wonderful
model in any case and if for private we
have a library called cache tools which
means that you would be decorating your
code with like a decorator that looks
like that and you would both both those
libraries they have means to constrain
the size of your cache and they also
have means to pass around a vector
function for creating the catch so it
could be injecting that vector function
I will talk about that in a couple of
slides what it means to inject stuff and
you could actually take care about the
dimensioning of your caches elsewhere in
the system which is a good thing because
if it's not always apparent when you're
going to run out of memory and two or
got like the principal users okay any
questions about that
so here the actually there is a static
variable called in the cache it's called
count once and it's a functional
composition of a function that lookups
looks up a certain dictionary and this
function does you see here so it's you
still have a global cache which connects
me to the next yeah so the problem is
wrapping this in the cache in class
means that you'll be rewriting the same
logic of like check stuff is it check if
stuff in the cache right and then you'll
be writing to lookups explicitly which
is kind of which couldn't produce a lot
of variance between different people
doing that inside the same codebase and
make it difficult when you decide to
readjust the cache sizes to see how to
do it so it's possible to do it in a
class and have relevant catch and
instance variable but class a it's
slightly less elegant so let me get to
the next slide and then I have some
notes about that yeah so first of all
like I mean that's more or less the
better way to go so it's not a silver
bullet the cache tools are not very nice
about caching complex objects so they
have a so to catch you need to calculate
the hash of the key like the objects
that you're passing to the function and
their implementation is not that good
something that I've shared the be one of
the guys that was working with this
current and so it's not kind of perfect
for every use case you could write your
own containers for uber and like the
whole thing works only for static to
functions or module level functions and
it will break horribly in I mean what
really break on instance on instance
methods
but it could cause a very serious bug
because it will essentially mean that
you are keeping an extra reference to
that instance right you'll be because
all instances if I can receive the South
pointer right self reference and that
would mean that you are leaking
instances of whatever thing you're
catching this way so that's not very
good in twiddle we wrote like videos
some dark Python metric and brought the
decorator that creates a hidden instance
attribute and put stuff there so special
handling for this specific problem and
yeah one thing I wanted to mention also
which is kind of orthogonal to
everything I talked about is that if you
rely on huge caches then you should
consider storing them on the disk
explicitly and not relying on a paging
outside that and there is a great
library called LM DB which is a key
value store that you that's very high
performance and you can just put stuff
on your disk and it's extremely quick
it's written C and so that's very nice
strategy okay so here is a we write the
next section which is about dependency
injection okay so a the reduction is
nothing wrong in this code yeah so it
just I mean it processed some data and
it looks some stuff but first of all
it's not kind of confined to best
practices with respect to logging and
also so there is something here that
it's furnished not kind of the best
thing the bugging is not the right tool
here because you're logging how many
records you got for your data and it it
usually means so this is fine I mean it
this is fine as long as you're running
your own data pipeline on your own
machine but probably when you're running
stuff in your production environment you
will want to
write this down as a business metric
right like how many records will
processed on any given location so it's
not really it's tough to be long and so
that's one problem that we see here but
that's not the reason I showed you this
code actually I wanted like so this code
has something nice and it's like pretty
like obvious and pretty hidden so it has
actually this magic object
I mean module logging and you get good
stuff out of it and it's just there
right you don't need to do like a lot of
work to get it there so it's and
somebody else takes care of setting it
up for you right so in here main one you
configure it and then if you want a
different configuration could do it a
different configuration and then you're
like code just can access that right so
am I making sense here
it's any questions yeah so this is
important for the next part so first of
all the right thing way to do logging is
by creating a little bit per module so
then you can see when you get the stuff
loaded you can see what module created
it so this is this piece right you'll
get the root name that's standard idiom
for Python and but like well the more
important part so there is a more
advanced technology that's called
dependency injection and the bend
injection is a way of passing objects to
inside your code which you kind of take
care about very explicitly so you are
you can be very picky about what objects
you pass is not just like a global
variable like the module logging you can
be like very fine-tuned about what you
get in there and the way it works is
like that so in this example I created
an auxiliary object called task
execution resources which is a bunch of
stuff that's probably useful for you
when you're running a data pipeline so
it includes some kind of metrics sync so
metric sync is something that you can
send metrics so and include the data
source and and then you do some helper
logic
and the record looks like that right you
a so in this specific framework which is
open source plate we go you get your
metrics a path so your context is passed
to us
as arguments your function and then you
can just fit your data like this so you
can just access
the right data source pops up inside
your code without you actually asking
for specific data source so where does
that come from so that comes from this
part you are declaring that for the
purpose of this test context thing you
your metrics will be this thing and your
data source will be this thing and then
when you come to your code you kind of
just can use them without asking for
specific a base or sort of metrics
engine is this making sense like yeah so
yeah and then when you are kind of
reaching production then you won't need
to change a single line in you're likely
to sense apparent you just need to pass
like more serious objects as your
metrics Inc and this your data source so
that's kind of the gist of it so when
you're at the end so the main points
that I'd like you to think about like I
mean it's undoing my top right is a you
your code is really a contract between
you and people maintaining that code
which could also be you it could also be
other people and so you know what I'm
showing you here is the kind of an ethic
so how to demarcate or how to like put a
border between stuff you do and put like
and stuff other people be doing so that
you're kind of constructed to help in
each other and everything now so so
that's one idea
hey which is by the way something I dip
liquid limit so should be helping other
people and like making their lives
easier and
second thing is that you should consider
like your internal data structures which
are good for processing stuff separate
from those that are useful for accessing
stuff and consider the kind of abuse
that accessing stuff entails so for
instance your users could be overwriting
your data things like that so you should
probably be by equally you should
consider at least what will happen if
you use or kind of a delete stuff that
you catch store which is worse
right so stuff over stuff that you would
catch and okay so and also things that
we didn't touch completely and are
pretty important so I should pay home
which is about a if you like didn't
learn yet about like how doing
test-driven development that is only
recommend that you do and in any case a
naming convention is if we speak about
helping other people that's kind of the
number one way of doing that and those
are the takeaways any questions to do
more dependency injection mode when you
try to use like some folks
multiprocessing or you try to execute
these software like yeah so something
was actually using spark to I mean I was
doing so girls hey you should remember
that like but anything running in PI
spark and then these regular Python code
so you will so if you want that variable
to be initialized you will need to arm
it with the right bait right with the
right and metrics and stuff like that
but yeah a and the library specifically
is the thread safe so it was written it
with multi-threading in mind and with
respect multi processing so each of the
processes well if if you arm it before
you fork then the processes share that
resource and if not then it's kind of
finish
in each of the subprocesses before it
kind of depends on what you do right
because you know let's take it offline
so in this part is about calculating
functions right so practically means
that no other wants now it's part is
about calculating functions right so a
and these functions don't come with the
context of dependency injection with
them so you always would initialize this
thing inside your function so what you
usually do in SPARC is you just catch so
you may not memorize like the things I
showed you you catch the relevant
context so it's it doesn't have to be
recalculated each time you make the
spice Park function call and then you
just use the cached value to arm your
injection and use the very inside your
code okay so that's like you're using
Python to quickly elaborate because I
think classes yes so so Python PI means
are very nice if you don't know about
type-ins use them and by the 3.7 has
data classes a but the thing is that you
sometimes want to validate the values
that you're getting in runtime because
that means won't protect you from a bad
piece of code passing your stuff around
it's useful as a hint for developers and
for some static type checking code but
if you get to a large enough code base
and like we had gotten too large you
know code base and you'll be kind of you
would have kind of you like UFO objects
get getting past them so and that means
won't help you
one reason that
it was often mentioned like when I was
discussing that was that Python 2 is
still slightly more efficient and if
you're running a high performance
application which to do is then you do
care about every inch of performance
okay
[Music]
[Applause]